je pourrais avoir le 3d carte une pioche
plusieurs groupes ses élèves de cp ce1
ce2 jouer au jeu des 7 familles un jeu
un peu différent puisqu'il a été pensé
par deux juristes et contient de
nouvelles cartes
on sait respirer de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
était signe en 89 pacifiant 89 et on
voulait vraiment leur montrer que ce
n'était pas juste des droits et des
devoirs mais c'était aussi grave
s'amuser le droit d'être soigné
voilà le droit d'avoir un travail c'est
un jeu ludique qui a été breveté par
l'agglomération pour faire découvrir
plus facilement la citoyenneté aux
enfants c'est l'école rosa-bonheur qui a
expérimenté pour la première fois ce jeu
en classe c'était quand même bien de
bien intéressant ils ont commencé à
faire attention à ce qui se passe et
faire attention aux échanges faire
attention aux mots qui circulait donc
c'était pas mal ça a pris un petit peu
le travail de groupe
en dehors du vocabulaire donc il y avait
pas mal de choses qui étaient à
exploiter exploitables comprendre les
mots apprendre de nouveaux métiers et
savoir différencier les droits des
devoirs
c'est ce que les élèves ont appris
durant la session du jeu c'est des
métiers qui sont dans la vraie vie la
vie le médecin la gt chose pour sécurité
l'avait déchausse la vt d'un disque et
prend soin autant un outil pédagogique
qui sera distribué à toutes les écoles
volontaires dans le département des
yvelines